in total three million six hundred and
eighty one thousand two hundred and
ninety five tests have been carried out
in the UK including a hundred and nine
thousand nine hundred and seventy nine
yesterday two hundred and sixty-five
thousand two hundred and twenty seven
people have tested positive that's an
increase of two thousand and four cases
since yesterday sadly of those who've
tested positive for coronavirus across
all settings thirty seven thousand and
forty eight people have now died
yesterday across the UK a hundred and
thirty-four deaths were reported but for
the first time since the 18th of March
I am very encouraged to confirm that
yesterday there were no deaths from
coronavirus recorded in Northern Ireland
I want to pay tribute to Robin Swan my
opposite number and all those across the
NHS and public health in Northern
Ireland and the people of Northern
Ireland who have shown such resolve to
be able to bend the curve down and thank
them for the work that they've done
while the news may not be this positive
every day I look forward very much to
working with them to keep the virus
under control in Northern Ireland
today's figures from the office for
national statistics show across the UK
as a whole the lowest number of deaths
from coronavirus for six weeks this is a
national endeavor and whatever the
headwinds as a country we can't let up
on this we past the peak we're
flattening the curve we protected the
NHS the number of deaths is falling we
must keep our resolve and I also want to
say a massive thank you to everybody
over the bank holiday weekend who stuck
to the social distancing rules and
especially to my colleagues in the NHS
and in social care who are doing so much
even though we're past the peak there
are still 8,000
and 802 people in hospital with
coronavirus in the UK and there is still
98 NHS colleagues in hospital with
coronavirus including some who are
seriously ill so we must maintain our
focus and there's two areas that I'd
like to provide an update on today both
incredibly important for the future of
tackling this disease PPE and treatments
first we've been working hard to build
our supplies of personal protective
equipment I know how important this is
especially to colleagues on the
frontline we all heard in the early
weeks of the crisis the calls from the
frontline for more and better PPE and we
all saw the global scramble to acquire
it I have been completely open about the
scale and the difficulties of this
challenge building a new supply chain
from scratch and of course the
operational challenge of delivery
General Sir Nick Carter chief of the
Defence Staff said himself this is the
single greatest logistical challenge
that he'd faced in his 40 years of
service and in response to those
challenges thanks to the Armed Forces
and to so many others including so many
in the NHS we've seen a mammoth effort
we've ramped up domestic production I
can announce that we have now signed
contracts to manufacture 2 billion items
of PPE here in the UK I set a national
challenge and I'm absolutely delighted
that Lord Dayton has stepped up and is
helping us to deliver against it around
the world we've signed deals with over a
hundred new suppliers including agreeing
contracts for a further three point
seven billion gloves while we continue
to improve the logistics and work hard
to get everyone the PPE that they need
these new supplies mean that we're not
simply keeping up with demand we are now
able to begin to replenish our
stockpiles there is a lot further to go
on PPE as on so many things but we have
made significant progress and I'd like
to thank everyone
involved and peepee of course is so
important because it's about protecting
the people who protect us and we'll do
that for as long as the virus remains on
these shores the next thing I wanted to
update you on is some of the remarkable
R&D into treatments that is taking place
across the UK one of Britain's greatest
strengths is our life sciences and in
particular our life sciences research
and we're leading the world in the
clinical trials that are being done here
as I said at this podium last week the
very nature of scientific inquiry means
that not every project will bear fruit
but I'm determined that we'll explore
every possible Avenue the recovery trial
is the world's largest trial of
potential coronavirus treatments and
because our NHS is a universal system in
which we're all part of we have some of
the best data and can do some of the
best research today I can announce that
we're beginning a new trial for selected
NHS patients of an antiviral drug called
REM Desiree they've already been some
promising early results on coronavirus
patients with early data suggesting it
can shorten recovery time by around four
days as you can understand
we'll be prioritizing the use of this
treatment where it will provide the
greatest benefit this is probably the
biggest step forward in the treatment of
coronavirus since the crisis began these
are very early steps but we're
determined to support the science and
back the projects that show promise I'd
like to thank the NHS the MHRA the
devolved administration's because this
is UK wide and Gilead the pharmaceutical
company for their work in making it
happen after all it's worth remembering
that in the battle against this virus we
are all on the same side so we'll keep
working across the world to develop the
vaccines and the treatments like this
that will help us turn a corner